mais 1988 fut pire avec 440 décès.
Que se passe-t-il ?
1988 a-t-elle été une année particulièrement mauvaise ?
Ou, ces améliorations sont un signe que le monde - malgré tous ses défis -
s'améliore au fil des années ?
Pourrions-nous même invoquer l'ancienne notion de progrès ?
Le faire risque de créer une certaine dérision,
parce que j'ai trouvé que les intellectuels détestent le progrès.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Et ceux qui s'appellent eux-mêmes progressifs détestent vraiment le progrès.
(Rires)
Ce n'est pas qu'ils détestent les résultats du progrès.
La plupart des universitaires et des experts
préféreraient subir une chirurgie avec l'anesthésie que sans.
C'est l'idée de progrès qui les rend bavards.
Si vous croyez que les humains peuvent améliorer leur sort, m'a-t-on dit,
cela signifie que vous avez une foi aveugle
et une croyance quasi-religieuse dans la superstition démodée
et la fausse promesse du mythe de la marche en avant
du progrès inexorable.
Vous êtes un partisan de la méthode Coué américaine
avec l'idéologie des conseils d'administration
de la Silicon Valley et de la Chambre de Commerce.
Vous êtes un praticien de l'histoire Whig,
un optimiste naïf, un Pollyanna et, bien sûr, un Pangloss,
le personnage de Voltaire qui a déclaré :
«Tout est pour le mieux dans le meilleur des mondes possibles. »
Eh bien, le professeur Pangloss était un pessimiste.
Un optimiste croit
qu'il peut y avoir de meilleurs mondes que le nôtre.
Mais tout ça n'est pas pertinent,
parce que la question de savoir si le progrès a eu lieu
n'est pas une question de foi,
ou de tempérament optimiste voyant le verre à moitié plein.
C'est une hypothèse qu'on peut tester.
Malgré leurs différences,
les gens sont largement d'accord sur le bien-être humain :
vie, santé, subsistance, prospérité, paix, liberté, sécurité, connaissance,
loisirs, bonheur.
Ces choses peuvent être mesurées.
Si elles se sont améliorées, alors c'est un progrès.
Regardons les données,
en commençant par le plus précieux : la vie.
Dans l'Histoire, l'espérance de vie est restée aux alentours de 30 ans.
Aujourd'hui, dans le monde, c'est plus de 70,
et dans les régions développées,
plus de 80.
Il y a 250 ans, dans les pays les plus riches au monde,
un tiers des enfants mouraient avant leur cinquième anniversaire,
avant que cette probabilité ne soit divisée par cent.
Aujourd'hui, cela arrive à moins de six pour cent des enfants
dans les pays les plus pauvres.
La famine est l'un des quatre cavaliers de l'Apocalypse,
et peut apporter la dévastation dans n'importe quelle partie du monde.
Aujourd'hui, la famine ne concerne plus
que les régions les plus ravagées par la guerre.
Il y a 200 ans, 90% de la population mondiale
subsistait dans l'extrême pauvreté.
Aujourd'hui, c'est moins de 10%.
Pendant la plupart de l'histoire humaine, les États et les empires étaient
à peu près toujours en guerre les uns avec les autres,
et la paix était un simple interlude entre les guerres.
Aujourd'hui, ils ne sont jamais en guerre.
La dernière guerre
était les États-Unis contre la Chine il y a 65 ans.
Récemment, les guerres sont devenues moins nombreuses et moins mortelles.
Le nombre annuel de morts est tombé d'environ 22 par cent mille par an
au début des années 50, à 1,2 aujourd'hui.
La démocratie a subi des revers évidents
au Venezuela, en Russie, en Turquie
et est menacée par la hausse du populisme autoritaire
en Europe de l'Est et aux États-Unis.
Pourtant, le monde n'a jamais été plus démocratique
que dans la dernière décennie,
avec les deux tiers des personnes vivant dans des démocraties.
Les taux d'homicide plongent à chaque fois que l'anarchie et le code de vendetta
sont remplacés par le droit.
C'est arrivé à l'Europe féodale en passant sous le contrôle de royaumes centralisés,
et aujourd'hui, un Européen de l'Ouest
a 35 fois moins de chance d'être assassiné
que ses ancêtres médiévaux.
C'est aussi arrivé en Nouvelle-Angleterre,
dans le Far West américain quand les shérifs ont déménagé en ville,
et au Mexique.
En effet, tout est devenu plus sûr.
Au cours du siècle dernier, nous sommes devenus 96% moins susceptibles
d'être tué dans un accident de voiture,
88% moins susceptibles d'être fauché sur le trottoir,
99 % moins susceptibles de mourir dans un accident d'avion,
95 % moins susceptibles d'être tué au travail,
89 % moins susceptibles d'être tué par un acte de Dieu,
comme une sécheresse, inondation, feu de forêt, tempête, volcan,
glissement de terrain, tremblement de terre ou météore,
probablement pas parce que Dieu est devenu moins en colère
mais grâce aux améliorations de notre infrastructure.
Et à propos de l'acte de Dieu par excellence,
le projectile lancé par Zeus lui-même ?
Oui, nous sommes 97% moins susceptibles d'être tué par un éclair.
(Rires)
Avant le 17ème siècle,
pas plus de 15% des Européens savaient lire ou écrire.
L'Europe et les USA ont atteint l'alphabétisation universelle
au milieu du 20ème siècle,
et le reste du monde rattrape.
Aujourd'hui, plus de 90% de la population mondiale
de moins de 25 ans sait lire et écrire.
Au 19ème, les Occidentaux travaillaient plus de 60 heures par semaine.
Aujourd'hui, ils travaillent moins de 40.
Grâce à l'eau courante et à l'électricité
dans le monde développé
et à l'adoption généralisée de machines à laver, aspirateurs,
réfrigérateurs, lave-vaisselle, four et micro-ondes,
le temps accordé aux tâches ménagères
est tombé de 60 heures par semaine
à moins de 15 heures par semaine.
Est-ce que ces gains en matière de santé, richesse, sécurité et loisirs
nous rendre plus heureux ?
La réponse est oui.
Dans 86% des pays du monde,
le bonheur a augmenté au cours des dernières décennies.
J'espère vous avoir convaincus
que le progrès n'est pas une question de foi ou d'optimisme,
mais est un fait de l'histoire humaine !
Le plus grand fait de l'histoire humaine.
Et comment ce fait a été couvert dans les journaux ?
(Rires)
Une étude sur le langage utilisé dans les journaux
a montré que pendant les décennies où l'humanité est devenue
plus riche, plus sage, plus sûre et plus heureuse,
le New York Times est devenu de plus en plus morose
et les émissions de télé sont devenues plus maussades.
Pourquoi les gens n'apprécient-ils pas le progrès ?
Une partie de la réponse vient de notre psychologie cognitive.
Nous estimons les risques en utilisant « l'heuristique de disponibilité ».
Plus il nous est facile de nous rappeler quelque chose,
le plus nous le jugeons probable.
L'autre partie de la réponse vient de la nature du journalisme,
capturé dans ce titre satirique de « The Onion » :
« CNN organise une réunion pour décider
sur quoi les téléspectateurs devraient paniquer. »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Les nouvelles parlent de choses qui arrivent, pas de ce qui n'arrive pas.
Vous ne voyez jamais un journaliste dire :
« Je rapporte en direct d'un pays en paix pendant 40 ans »
ou d'une ville qui n'a pas subi d'attaque terroristes.
De plus, les mauvaises choses arrivent rapidement,
et les bonnes ne se construisent pas en un jour.
Les journaux pourraient titrer :
« 137 000 personnes sont sorties de l'extrême pauvreté hier »
tous les jours sur les 25 dernières années.
C'est 1,25 milliard de personnes.
Mais vous n'avez rien vu sur ce sujet.
En outre, les nouvelles capitalisent sur notre intérêt morbide
à ce qui peut mal tourner :
« Si le sang coule, le sujet sera porteur. »
Si vous combinez nos biais cognitifs avec la nature des journaux,
vous pouvez voir pourquoi le monde prend fin
depuis très longtemps.
Je vais répondre à des questions sur le progrès
que, sans doute, vous connaissez.
D'abord, n'est-ce pas bon d'être pessimiste
pour se protéger contre la complaisance,
et pour dire leur vérité aux puissants ?
Eh bien, pas exactement.
C'est bon d'être précis.
Nous devons être conscients du danger et de la souffrance où qu'ils se produisent,
mais nous devons aussi savoir comment ils peuvent être réduits,
parce qu'il y a des dangers au pessimisme aveugle.
L'un d'eux est le fatalisme.
Si tous nos efforts pour améliorer le monde
ont été inutiles,
pourquoi continuer d'essayer ?
Les pauvres seront toujours là.
Et puisque le monde se terminera bientôt -
si le changement climatique ne nous tue pas,
l'intelligence artificielle le fera -
la réponse est de profiter de la vie pendant que nous le pouvons,
mange, bois et sois heureux, car demain, nous mourrons.
L'autre danger du pessimisme irréfléchi est le radicalisme.
Si nos institutions échouent toutes - au-delà de l'espoir d'une réforme -
une réponse naturelle est de chercher à casser la machine,
assainir les marais,
brûler l'empire,
avec l'espoir que, peu importe ce qui sortira des cendres,
ça sera mieux que ce que nous avons maintenant.
S'il y a une telle chose que le progrès,
quelles en sont les causes ?
Le progrès n'est pas une force mystique qui nous élève toujours plus haut.
Ce n'est pas une histoire mystérieuse vers la justice.
C'est le résultat d'efforts humains gouvernés par une idée,
une idée que nous associons avec les Lumières du 18ème siècle,
à savoir que si nous appliquons la raison et la science
pour améliorer le bien-être humain,
nous pouvons réussir progressivement.
Le progrès est-il inévitable ? Bien sûr que non.
Le progrès ne veut pas dire que tout va mieux
pour tout le monde, partout, et tout le temps.
Ce serait un miracle, et le progrès n'est pas un miracle,
mais la résolution de problèmes.
Les problèmes sont inévitables
et les solutions créent de nouveaux problèmes devant être résolus à leur tour.
Les problèmes non résolus aujourd'hui sont gargantuesques y
y compris les risques climatiques et la guerre nucléaire,
mais nous devons les voir comme des problèmes à résoudre,
pas des apocalypses à venir,
et rechercher activement des solutions
comme la décarbonisation profonde pour le climat
et Global Zero pour la guerre nucléaire.
Enfin, est-ce que les Lumières vont contre la nature humaine ?
C'est une question aiguë pour moi,
parce que je suis un avocat éminent de l'existence de la nature humaine,
avec toutes ses lacunes et perversités.
Dans « The Blank Slate »,
j'ai soutenu que la perspective humaine est plus tragique qu'utopique.
Nous ne sommes pas des poussières d'étoiles
et il n'y a aucun moyen de retourner au jardin.
(Rires)
Mais ma vision du monde s'est éclaircie
dans les 15 années depuis « The Blank Slate ».
Ma connaissance des statistiques du progrès humain,
à partir de la violence
mais maintenant englobant les autres aspects de notre bien-être,
a fortifié ma croyance
que dans la compréhension de nos tribulations et de nos malheurs,
la nature humaine est le problème,
mais la nature humaine, canalisée par les institutions des Lumières,
est aussi la solution.
Certes, ce n'est pas facile de reproduire mon épiphanie axée sur les données
avec l'humanité en général.
Certains intellectuels ont répondu
avec fureur à mon livre « Enlightenment Now »,
en disant : comment ose-t-il prétendre que les intellectuels détestent le progrès ?
Et aussi, comment ose-t-il réclamer qu'il y a eu des progrès ?
(Rires)
L'idée de progrès laisse certains froids.
Sauver la vie de milliards de gens,
éradiquer les maladies, nourrir les affamés,
apprendre aux enfants à lire ?
Ennuyeux.
Mais, la réponse la plus commune que j'ai reçue était de la gratitude.
Gratitude de changer leur vision du monde
d'un fatalisme engourdi et sans défense
à quelque chose de plus constructif,
même héroïque.
Je crois que les idéaux des Lumières
peuvent être un récit émouvant,
et j'espère que des gens, plus artistiques,
plus rhétoriques, que moi,
pourraient mieux le dire.
Voici mon exemple.
Nous sommes nés dans un univers sans pitié,
face à des chances abruptes contre l'ordre de la vie
et en danger constant de tomber en morceaux.
Nous avons été façonnés par un processus impitoyablement compétitif.
Fabriqués à partir de bois tordu,
vulnérable aux illusions, à l'égocentrisme
et parfois d'une stupidité stupéfiante.
Mais, la nature humaine a aussi été bénie de ressources
laissant la place à une sorte de rédemption.
Nous pouvons combiner des idées de manière récursive,
avoir des pensées sur nos pensées.
Nous avons un instinct pour le langage,
nous permettant de partager les fruits
de notre ingéniosité et de nos expériences.
Nous avons développé une capacité à la sympathie,
à la pitié, à l'imagination, à la compassion, à la commisération.
Ces dons ont trouvé des moyens pour magnifier leur propre pouvoir.
La portée du langage a été augmentée
par l'écrit, l'imprimé et les mots électroniques.
Notre cercle de sympathie a été élargi
par l'histoire, le journalisme et les arts narratifs.
Et nos facultés rationnelles chétives ont été multipliées
par les normes et les institutions de la raison,
de la curiosité intellectuelle, du débat,
du scepticisme face à l'autorité et au dogme,
et par le fardeau de la preuve pour vérifier les idées
en les confrontant à la réalité.
Alors la spirale de l'amélioration récursive accélère,
nous sortons des victoires contre les forces qui nous écrasent,
dont les parties les plus sombres de notre propre nature.
Nous pénétrons les mystères du cosmos, y compris la vie et l'esprit.
Nous vivons plus longtemps, souffrons moins, apprenons plus,
devenons plus intelligents et profitons plus de petits plaisirs
et des expériences riches.
Moins d'entre nous sont tués, agressés, asservis, exploités
ou opprimés par les autres.
De quelques oasis, les territoires de paix et de prospérité grandissent
et pourraient un jour recouvrir toute la Terre.
Il reste beaucoup de souffrance,
ainsi que d'énormes périls,
mais des idées sur la façon de les réduire ont été exprimées,
et un nombre infini d'autres doivent encore être conçues.
Nous n'aurons jamais un monde parfait,
et il serait dangereux d'en chercher un.
Mais il n'y a pas de limite aux améliorations possibles
de l'épanouissement humain.
Cette histoire héroïque n'est pas juste un autre mythe.
Les mythes sont des fictions, mais celui-ci est vrai,
fidèle à nos connaissances, ce qui est la seule vérité que nous pouvons avoir.
Comme nous en apprenons plus, nous pouvons montrer
quelles parties de l'histoire continuent d'être vraies et lesquelles sont fausses,
et surveiller leur évolution.
Cette histoire n'appartient à aucune tribu
mais à toute l'humanité,
à toute créature sensible avec le pouvoir de la raison
et l'envie de persister dans son être,
car il ne nécessite que les convictions
que la vie est meilleure que la mort,
la santé est meilleure que la maladie,
l'abondance est meilleure que le vouloir,
la liberté est meilleure que la coercition,
le bonheur vaut mieux que la souffrance
et la connaissance est meilleure que l'ignorance et la superstition.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)